si on l'a adressé tout à l'heure au
président de la république on ignore
pour l'instant s'il a été acceptée par
françois mitterrand l'opposition se
concertent sur la conduite à tenir à
propos du référendum le texte soumis au
vote devrait être connu demain après le
conseil des ministres
encore et toujours laurent fignon le
champion français s'est adjugé l'étape
d'aujourd'hui dans le rhône alpe d'huez
et la plagne il a maintenant
pratiquement course gagnée
et puis l'évasion spectaculaire à la
prison de barcelone où sept danseurs se
sont échappés ce matin malgré une
fusillade
mesdames messieurs bonsoir nous l'avons
appris il y à un peu plus d'une heure le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
monsieur savary a présenté sa démission
ne sait pas pour l'instant si le chef de
l'état l'a accepté une initiative qui
intervient au moment même où le monde
politique se mobilisent en vue du
référendum prévu pour le mois de
septembre
et vous vous souvenez que le président
de la république a choisi cette
procédure en raison notamment des
problèmes soulevés par le débat sur
l'enseignement privé en france même si
ce n'est pas la raison unique de sa
décision
cela dit la démission de monsieur savary
n'est pas à proprement parler une
surprise puisqu'il avait déjà souhaité
quitter son poste au mois de mai dernier
lors du débat de l'assemblée nationale
sur la loi qui porte son nom
dominique laurie alain savary est sans
doute aujourd'hui très amer deux ans et
demi de négociations pour un texte
retiré le tempérament du personnage
l'incitent à ne plus vouloir rester au
gouvernement malgré l'hommage du
président de la république samedi
dernier moi je pense que c'est une bonne
loi
je pense qu'elle est jugée de façon très
injuste
je pense qu'une chasse avrillais fait un
travail honnête considérable pendant une
très longue négociation qui a duré peut
être deux ans donc mais cette opinion
que j'ai il est visible qu'il n'est pas
partagé par un très grand nombre de
français
alors comme je l ai dit tout à l'heure à
monsieur mozy je m'inquiète aussi de ce
que pensent ceux qui ne pensent pas
comme moi et j'en tiens compte
depuis deux ans et demi le ministre de
l'éducation nationale s'est battu sur
tous les fronts à l'assemblée contre
l'opposition mais également au ministère
pour défendre un projet contesté par
l'enseignement privé comme par les
partisans de l'école laïque diplomate
alain savary a tenté l'impossible réunir
les deux camps dès les premières
négociations 82 le cnal refuse la
première version du texte une
modification s'impose
mais c'est alors l'enseignement privé
qui quitte la table des négociations
chaque manifestation dans les deux camps
sera marquée par des slogans hostiles à
al un ça va
homme de sang froid le ministre ne
montre jamais son découragement une
négociation toujours recommencée malgré
les blocages les manifestations les
critiques tous azimuts
ironie du sort alain savary ne cachait
pas ses réticences à l'égard d'un projet
qui portait son nom il le trouvait
excessif et militer en privé pour un
texte plus conciliant en présentant sa
démission il reste fidèle à lui même ne
jamais séparer 10 est il moral et
politique
simon roy vient tout juste d'arriver à
l'elysée il s'est refusé pour l'instant
à confirmer ou démentir l'éventuelle
démission de monsieur savard
alors si la démission d'alain farde
savary n'est pas une surprise elle prend
aujourd'hui albert du roy valeur de
symbole en raison des l'allocution du
chef de l'état jeudi dernier oui il le
coup de chapeau rendu à l'homme
alain savary et à la loi savary par le
chef de l'état samedi dans son interview
à tf1 à l'occasion du 14 juillet n'aura
donc pas suffi il est vrai que annulée
comme ça d'un coup deux ans et demi de
négociations c'est dur et surtout que
ces deux années et demi ont été
particulièrement dure à vivre pour alain
savary il avait bataillé pour trouver un
point d'équilibré entre le camp du privé
et le camp du public et c'est l'une des
querelles les plus empoisonné de la vie
politique française et des points
équilibre il en avait trouvé n'avait
trouvé de nombreux que chacun
reconnaissait dans son texte de loi il
avait ensuite batailler pour éviter des
concessions de dernière minute fait
finalement au clan laïc par le premier
ministre pierre mauroy et ce moment là
il avait même
envisageait de démissionner et
finalement il avait décidé d'assumer la
paternité d'un texte qu'ils savaient
impopulaire de tous les côtés à n'en pas
douter on saluera le courage et
d'honnêteté de cet homme politique dont
la carrière politique a commencé
maintenant il ya 40 ans et depuis 40 ans
en saluant son courage et son honnêteté
des qualités qui n'ont pas toujours été
payés de retour
ça veut aussi dire que la tâche sera
très difficile pour le successeur
alors oui maintenant on a fait table
rase il n'ya plus de projet de loi
savary
il n'ya plus d'alain savary sa
domination nationale il aura un
successeur ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
ce successeur aura deux caractéristiques
d'abord ce sera très probablement un
proche du président de la république un
homme en qui font ça mitterrand a pleine
confiance car c'est l'enseignement le
dossier clé sur lequel on s'est mis
terran sera jugé dans les mois qui
viennent il ne serait donc pas étonnant
que ce soit un proche collaborateur
actuels ou passés du chef de l'état qui
soit nommé à ce poste à sera ensuite
deuxième qualité
un homme de dialogue et qui d'emblée
devrait faire bonne impression aux uns
et aux autres car le président cherche
sur ce problème très compliqué une
solution de compromis et toujours pas de
confirmation à l'elysée où le premier
ministre est donc depuis quelques
minutes
alors en marge de cette affaire c'est
demain que l'on connaîtra en principe le
texte qui sera soumis à référendum
après avoir été présentée aux deux
assemblées le conseil des ministres
devrait en discuter demain matin un
texte dont chaque mot était pesé et
analysé par les juristes de l'elysée
avant d'être soumis au conseil d'état
qui en a pris connaissance aujourd'hui
on en est là ce soir et les états majors
politiques attendent d'en savoir plus
pour déterminer leur position
c'est notamment le cas de l'opposition
qui paraît un peu embarrassé et qui a
choisi de juger sur pièce lorsque le
texte sera connue même si elle fait état
dès aujourd'hui d'une méfiance certaines
gens lui le cesne curieux retour des
choses c'est le sénat qui avait demandé
le référendum le président l'a accordé
est maintenant au palais du luxembourg
on renâcle
c'est sur l'école privée qu'on voulait
le référendum disent aujourd'hui les
sénateurs de l'opposition et pas sur la
constitution
à droite on avait plutôt bien accueilli
l'engagement présidentiel aujourd'hui
dans l'effervescence
même les plus modérés traîne les pieds
où je ne veux pas que le parlement soit
dessaisi de ses pouvoirs
vous savez dans un pays latin il faut
toujours se méfier de l'emploi
plébiscitaire et peut-être fait de
l'affairé
lorsque le président mitterrand était
dans l'opposition a mieux c'est que y
avait extrêmement méfiant à cet égard
cette méfiance
je la partage et je n'entends pas
laisser un président de la république
que peu d'initiatives en matière de
référé
c'est à l'udf que les divisions sont les
plus évidentes trouvé le moyen de dire
oui sans se laisser piéger au plébiscite
ou dire non sans passer pour opposants
aux libertés je crois que d'ores et déjà
on peut dire qu'il faut voter non au
référendum
pourquoi parce que bien fait sur le plan
juridique la sphère sera compliqué les
sénateurs et députés l'étudierons mais
en définitive lorsque la sphère viendra
devant les français lorsque les français
auront à voter ce référendum
pour eux les choses seront très clair il
s'agira de voter pour ou contre
mitterrand pour ou contre le régime
socialo communiste et par conséquent ma
réponse est claire à cette question il
faut voter non excusées votre honneur a
répondu du tac au tac jean claude gaudin
le président du groupe udf à l'assemblée
michel pinton n'a rien compris
on va discuter du texte du référendum on
proposera des amendements mais à partir
de là on ne sait pas s'il y aura ou non
référendum nous ne sommes pas là pour
répondre aujourd'hui par oui ou par non
sur un texte que nous n'avons pas encore
étudié par conséquent toute réponse est
pour l'instant prématuré
nous avons quelques jours avec nos amis
du sénat pour étudier la réponse que
nous devons faire sur le référendum
organisant le référendum
c'est ça la question donc que nous pose
le président de la république au moment
excusez moi de vous le dire où il ya
d'autres problèmes plus importants comme
le chômage qu'il faudrait régler plutôt
que de s'occuper d'obtenir un chiffre
pour permettre d'être consolidée c'est
ce que veut le président de la
république
du côté du rpr tous les
constitutionnalistes étaient présents à
l'assemblée
les gaullistes qui apprécient les
référendums n'aime pas celui-là en tout
cas la stratégie qui a réussi aux
européennes est maintenu nous ne ferons
rien qui aille dans un sens opposé à ce
que proposera en accord avec nous le
groupe de l'idf en fait les députés et
les sénateurs de l'opposition sont
troublés même sur le qui vive
une chose est sûre tout sera fait pour
gêner l'initiative présidentielle
en grande bretagne la situation demeure
toujours bloquée entre les dockers en
grève et le gouvernement et cela malgré
une réunion ce matin de la commission de
conciliation qui doit tenter de trouver
une solution
une situation qui déborde sur le
continent où des centaines de camions
sont bloqués en attendant la réouverture
des portes anglais jean le berre
le trafic marchandises était
complètement paralysée aujourd'hui dans
78 pour brittany dont celui de douvres
plusieurs centaines de camions européens
sont immobilisés de l'autre côté de la
manche
pour éviter les incidents la police
anglaise a parqué les camionneurs et
leurs camions sur une portion
d'autoroute neutralisée pour la
circonstance
côté voyageurs le trafic à douvres était
tout à fait normal quotidiennement
trente mille personnes 5000 voitures
particulières et 500 autocar transitent
par le plus grand terminal portuaire de
la grande bretagne
a calais trafic marchandises perturbé
200 camions attendaient aujourd'hui un
embarquement 200 camions
c'est la moyenne quotidienne de poids
lourds qui transitent par ce port pas
d'embouteillage important donc à calais
les transporteurs retard dans leurs
expéditions vers l'angleterre
côté touristes pas de problème il en bas
normalement et avec leur voiture
personnelle à cherbourg situation plus
difficile la tre klein à désarmer ses
deux bateaux le pearl buck et le
coutançais l'équipage est à quai 150
camions attendent un bateau et pour
certains le blocage a commencé vendredi
dernier
cet après midi les chauffeurs italiens
ont bloqué pour quelques minutes
les passerelles d'accès d'un ferry pour
les autres il commence à trouver le
temps long
ces problèmes et de manger des hot pour
les entreprises de transport comme pour
les compagnies maritimes
l'heure des comptes a déjà sonné et la
tre klein annoncé la mise en chômage
partiel de 238 navigant et employés
de prendre des mesures conservatoires
plus aucune recette ne rentre bien sûr
dans la compagnie vous avez vu le nombre
de parts camions qui sont actuellement
sur le parking je crois qu'en tout nous
avons 150 véhicules en attente
d'embarquement
nous sommes touchés tout comme nos
transporteurs à cherbourg comme dans les
autres ports français
on espère que le comité de conciliation
anglais débloquera rapidement la
situation
changement de climat dans les
négociations entre les syndicats et la
direction de citroën le pdg de cit run
monsieur calvet a reçu aujourd'hui la
cfdt et la cgt
le dialogue s'est semble-t-il engagées
notamment avec la cgt puisque la
rencontre a duré un peu plus de quatre
heures avec andré saint jean que la
direction avait jusqu'à présent refusé
de recevoir à l'issue de cette réunion
il ya eu un conseil d'administration
monsieur calvet va maintenant demander à
rencontrer pierre bérégovoy la cgt va
déposer de son côté la même requête
un nouvel indice satisfaisant pour le
gouvernement la réduction du rythme
d'endettement de la france depuis le
début de l'année ce n'est pas une baisse
mais un ralentissement l'endettement
extérieur de la france atteignent 4 166
4 milliards de francs à la fin du mois
de juin il y avait aujourd'hui un
conseil interministériel consacré à
l'emploi
les ministres concernés ont planché sur
les mesures concrètes à mettre au point
pour les contrats à durée déterminée et
l'insertion des jeunes
un conseil qui s'est tenu à la veille de
la publication des nouveaux chiffres de
l'emploi d'ailleurs les ministres
avaient certainement présentes à
l'esprit la situation en lorraine au
lendemain du plan acier et demain
jacques chérèque le nouveau préfet
chargé de l'industrialisation de cette
région
jacques chérèque fera connaître les
mesures de relance de l'emploi en
lorraine
mais dès ce soir roselyne koskas lève le
voile sur ces mesures
demain jacques chirac va annoncer la
création de près de 500 emplois de
nouveau en lorraine c'est une demi
douzaine de pme tout privé tout
industriel qui feront le voyage de la
lorraine attirés par les aides du
gouvernement
elles créeront chacune entre 50 et 100
emplois
c'est sympa en poids ville s'ajouter aux
200 fin comment annoncé il ya quelques
jours par qui connu pour cette les
minutes et surtout aux 4000 apporté au
mois d'avril dernier par laurent fabius
beaucoup d'entreprises on s'en souvient
on fait un effort pour la lorraine et
déjà nombre d'entre elles commencent à
s'implanter renoue créer 500 emplois
dans la mécanique et l'affichage
électronique
séité alcatel 250 pour des lasers et
thomson 500 emplois pour des
magnétoscopes et des composants côté
privé des travaux avancent pour éviter
qu'une société d'audiovisuel 200 emplois
et pour oric et ses micro ordinateurs
130 à 150 emplois près de 5000 emplois
nouveaux sont donc annoncés pour la
lorraine sinistrés mais vingt mille
postes de travail seront supprimés dans
la sidérurgie
voilà donc deux mois et demi que jacques
chérèque un ancien de la cfdt a été
nommé à son poste de responsable de
l'industrialisation lorraine
un préfet pas tout à fait comme les
autres d'abord parce que c'est un enfant
du pays
ensuite parce qu'il appartient un
syndicat qui n'a jamais mâché ses mots
son portrait par laurent carenzo et
michel alik of sourire aux lèvres le 3
mai dernier jacques chérèque le numéro
deux de la cfdt devenait préfet délégué
en lorraine objectif opérer leur
déploiement de cette région frappée par
la crise depuis le nouveau préfet a pris
ses fonctions à metz et traînant des
bureaux qui n'étaient pas prévus pour
lui un saut dans l'inconnu pour cet
homme truculent plus à l'aise de nature
dans les cantines du sinn que sous les
lambris préfectoraux avec bien entendu
quelques soucis domestiques on regarde
des chauffeurs parce que je travaille
j'ai quitté l'hôtel parce que je
retrouverai à l'hôtel
c'est bien l'hôte allemand ont lieu
militants jacques chérèque a pris sa
mission à bras le corps il garde son
franc parler et de réussir sa dernière
mission il sait que cette ultime
bataille ne sera pas facile et coups de
gueule existe les difficultés existent
quelques petites peaux de bananes par ci
par là quelques petits courants vache
mais ça j'allais j'allais dire que c'est
pas pour me surprendre je pensais bien
que j'arrivais point que j'arrivais pas
sur un livre aux je n'entends pas roulé
roulé carrosse préfectorale mais je
n'entends pas est un fonceur avait
j'entends est un vrai préfet et en même
temps à rester tout à fait moi même
après deux mois et demi de mission le
presser anticonformiste a réussi à se
couler dans le paysage de la lorraine
des contacts à tous les niveaux des
centaines de rencontres et le souci
d'échapper au poids des modalités
provincial en imposant ce qu'ils font
ces atouts la franchise et la
connaissance du terrain violente
carrie blanc me dis pourquoi les trois
années mon parti vous savez le fait de
bien connaître cette région à laquelle
j'ai vécu quarante ans le fait de
connaître les hommes et les femmes qui
vivent de connaître les différentes
situations économiques politiques et
donc de mettre derrière chaque dossier
un site géographique et des visages des
hommes des responsables patronaux de
mettre des responsables politiques de
mettre des responsables syndicaux de
mettre un environnement humain de mettre
un environnement culturel de mettre un
environnement politique c'est à dire de
donner une vie une vie presque charnelle
au dossier
c'est sa tête la nouvelle manière dans
une région en plein effondrement
sidérurgique jacques chérèque ne veux
pas jouer au zorro du redéploiement
il a pour l'instant réussi à localiser
les 4000 emplois promis par laurent
fabius et il en a encore 500 sous le
coude une drôle de conversion pour un
ancien syndicaliste après une ouverture
en panache et hier à san francisco les
délégués démocrate de l'acca la
convention de ce parti ses délégués sont
entrés aujourd'hui dans le vif du sujet
on avait un peu oublié les querelles de
personne pour s'en prendre à l'ennemi
numéro un
le président reagan le reportage de
notre envoyé spécial
edwards lors le coup d'oeil du maître et
le coup d'envoi de la 39e convention
démocrate quatre mises et les gains
visualise le titre est allé début
tant pour la modique somme de 6 millions
de dollars 50 millions de francs et avec
cette année la grande révélation chez
les démocrates n'ont pas walter mondale
le candidat le mieux placé mais elle
geraldine ferraro candidate à la vice
président
d'ailleurs les femmes en général le
maire de san francisco galvan stein
toutes les pas qui sont en novembre 6
millions de plus que les hommes à voter
pour l'élection présidentielle
l'enjeu est de taille les démocrates
comptent bien s'en servir dans
l'immédiat c'est pour quelques instants
avec émotion que les démocrates se sont
tournés vers leur passé gemini et
rosalynn carter
et me revoilà et la gorgue est en fait
le seul moment intéressant de cette
première journée d'une convention était
bien du mal à démarrer sans doute parce
qu on a déjà tous les éléments en main
le nom du futur candidat où elle
commande elle le nom proposé pour la
vice-présidence geraldine ferraro et les
grandes lignes de la plateforme
électorale dont on sait également
qu'elle a bien peu de chances de
l'emporter en novembre prochain
alors il reste à respecter la tradition
politique américaine qui veut une
convention soit aussi gigantesque
internet et cette fois encore à san
francisco cette année pendant quatre
jours et bien la tradition sera
respectée et le pasteur noir jesse
jackson doit tenir cette nuit un
discours important il permettra de
savoir de quelle façon il espère influer
sur la politique de son parti
grâce à l'énorme mobilisation de
l'électorat noir autour de son nom jesse
jackson qui a par ailleurs été invités à
se rendre en union soviétique coeur qui
peut battre aujourd'hui laurent fignon
c'est la question que l'on se pose ce
soir après la magnifique victoire du
maillot jaune dans l'étape de cet après
midi laurent fignon impérial s'est donc
payé le luxe de remporter cette étape de
montagne
alors qu'il lui suffisait de maintenir
tout juste son effort pour conserver la
première place au classement général
mais à 10 km de l'arrivée fignon s'est
proprement t'envoler laissant sur place
bernard hinault qui était resté jusque
là accroché à sa roue un moment un peu
pathétique car il était évident à 7
minutes que malgré tous ses efforts
hinault n'était pas de taille pour
contrer son adversaire patrick boitet
fignon lemond hinault les trois hommes
forts du peloton ensemble dans
l'ascension de la plagne pas pour
longtemps cyrille guimard montrent à la
hauteur du maillot jaune pour lui dire
d'attaqué et la belle mécanique se met
immédiatement en route un démarrage
meurtrier va décrocher tous ses
adversaires
devant le suisse jean marie grezet
résigné il sait que ces deux minutes
d'avancé ne tiendront pas longtemps face
à un maillot jaune survoltée qui fond
sur lui comme un aigle sur sa proie
derrière millar et delgado tentent de
limiter les dégâts et bernard hinault ne
se fait plus d'illusions fignon trop
fort pour lui le breton se bat
aujourd'hui contre lui même seul un
homme se révoltent contre la suprématie
humiliante du maillot jaune le champion
du monde greg lemon qui part en contre
attaque mais il ne pourra revenir sur un
super fignon bien décidé aujourd'hui à
épingler à son palmarès une grande étape
de montagne
c'est la troisième victoire dans ce tour
pour le champion de france qui prend à
l'arrivée plus d'une minute à creuser et
lemon
hinault 10e père lui trois minutes sur
le podium fignon radieux pense déjà son
deuxième type alors que lemon dérobe à
vincent barteau sa dernière tunis
annonce tout de suite à l'elysée où le
secrétaire général de la présidence
s'apprête à faire une déclaration de la
constitution le premier ministre
monsieur pierre mauroy a présenté au
président de la république la démission
de son gouvernement le président de la
république a accepté cette démission le
président de la république conformément
à l'article 8 de la constitution a nommé
premier ministre monsieur laurent fabius
sur merci voilà l'annoncent donc
immédiatement en direct par le
secrétaire général de la présidence de
la démission du gouvernement de pierre
mauroy
votre analyse à chaud albert ii roi
alors évidemment cette heure encore une
grande surprise la deuxième dans la même
semaine puisque l'annoncé du référendum
jeudi dernier était déjà une grande
surprise de réflexion avant d'en savoir
plus
la première c'est que le président la
république a décidément décidé de faire
tout à la fois d'abord l'appel au peuple
avec le référendum là le déblocage delà
de l'affrontement scolaire et ensuite le
changement du gouvernement le changement
de gouvernement on en parlait depuis
longtemps depuis même très longtemps on
a commencé à en parler au mois de mars
1983 après la défaite de la gauche aux
élections municipales à ce moment là
tout le monde a fait remarquer que le
gouvernement dirigé par monsieur pierre
moreau en termes au roy semblait à bout
de course et qu on a évoqué la
possibilité de la démission de ce
gouvernement du remplacement de monsieur
pierre mauroy il a été question à ce
moment là que jacques delors le ministre
de l'économie et des finances aïe à
matignon finalement le président de la
république avait alors décidé de
conserver pierre mauroy à matignon
probablement parce que il savait qu'avec
la politique de rigueur qui étaient
renforcés à ce moment là les mois qui
suivaient seraient les plus durs
la première partie de son septennat et
qu'ils ne serviraient ne servait à rien
d'user un autre premier ministre alors
que ces mois serait dur il s'agissait
donc de garder en place un premier
ministre qui avait l'expérience de la
gestion des affaires qui avaient la
confiance des deux partis de gauche et
qui était chargé de mener cette
politique de rigueur renforcée
alors maintenant le choix du successeur
le choix du successeur évidemment
c'était la question que tout le monde se
posait depuis qu'il était question du
remplacement de pierre mauroy
on citait pas mal de noms cités ceux de
louis mermaz de pierre bérégovoy parfois
de jacques delors éventuellement même de
michel rocard
finalement c'est laurent faible alors
laurent fabius c'est intéressant parce
que il correspond comme premier ministre
exactement au portrait-robot que je
faisais tout à l'heure du futur ministre
de l'éducation nationale qui devait
remplacer monsieur alain savary
c'est un proche du président je vais
revenir dans quelques instants il à
peine confiance et c'est un homme de
dialogue
proche du président monsieur fabius doit
avoir quelque chose comme 40 ans c'est
donc un jeune il était dans le
gouvernement démissionnaire
d'aujourd'hui il était ministre de
l'industrie il est rentré au parti
socialiste assez tard vers 1976 1977 et
d'emblée c'est un énarque un de plus
et d'emblée il avait été remarqué par
françois mitterrand alors leader de
l'opposition pour sa compétence
économique pour la clarté de cette
analyse la clarté de ses dossiers et
françois mitterrand l'avait pris comme
directeur de son cabinet il était tard
il était à ce moment là donc premiers
secrétaires du parti socialiste laurent
fabius
ensuite c'est la personnalité de rentrer
à bruxelles ce intéressante d'ailleurs
parce que tous sont tous ont toute sa
vie son éducation
le milieu bourgeois dans lequel il est
né le fait qu'il ait pu faire des études
supérieures donc jusqu à l'ena le
le faisait de nuit un le profil type du
jeune giscardien tels qu' on a eu
énormément dans les ministères dans les
gouvernements du président la république
précédents
et c'est simplement c'était toujours une
surprise de découvrir qu'il était qu'il
y avait a décidé d'adhérer au parti
socialiste et donc à ce moment là dès
cette époque là ça a été
et ça n'a jamais cessé d'être le l'un
des plus proches collaborateurs de du
présent la république de l'actuel
président de la république
ils sont enfin pour employer une terre
un terme à la mode ils sont en phase
l'un avec l'autre et donc il s'agissait
pour françois mitterrand de choisir un
homme avec lequel dans les mois et
peut-être les années qui viennent
il serait parfaitement en phase pour
être sûr d'être tout à fait compris de
lui
mais albert nous allons la qualité va
très vite ce soir effectivement avec
l'annoncé de la démission du
gouvernement de pierre mauroy et celui
du choix donc de laurent fabius comme
nouveau premier ministre
nous allons revenir tout à l'heure sur
laurent fabius mais tout de suite le
portrait de pierre mauroy qui a donc
jusqu'à ce jour mené les gouvernements
de françois mitterrand que c'est un
portrait de monsieur me roy qui a tout
juste d'être mauvais l'époque de l'état
de grâce durera un an
pierre mauroy se consacre à la
construction de ce qu'il appelle le
socle du changement et grandes réformes
sont mises en chantier et adopté plus ou
moins facilement par les parlementaires
la décentralisation les nationalisations
les droits des travailleurs
parallèlement le gouvernement augmente
le smic
les allocations familiales est institué
à l'impôt sur les grandes fortunes
la priorité des priorités pour pierre
mauroy c'est alors la lutte pour
l'emploi
il se fixe comme objectif la
stabilisation à 2 millions de chômeurs
pour fin 82 lors du tour de france qu'il
effectue pour expliquer cette politique
les français découvrent le style mauroy
mêlée de rondeur et de générosité
je vous dis comme premier ministre je
préfère dépenser de l'argent pour payer
des caisses de retraite ou pour payer
des caisses de formation professionnelle
plutôt que de dépenser de l'argent pour
payer des caisses de chômage voilà
vous voyez c'est aussi simple que ça
d'être premier ministre d'être au
gouvernement gouverner autrement c'est
sa devise
et pour compléter son dispositif le
gouvernement adopte les ordonnances
sociales semaine de 39 heures cinquième
semaine de congés payés retraite à 60
ans formation professionnelle des jeunes
contrat de solidarité
cette politique provoque quelques
tiraillements au sein du gouvernement la
croissance forte sur laquelle il
comptait n'est pas au rendez vous le
franc a subi une première dévaluation de
fait et les mesures sociales coûte cher
en novembre jacques delors demande déjà
plus de rigueur
une pause dans les réformes
pierre mauroy frire et sommes résolus à
les mener ses réformes sans accélération
ni précipitation mais de manière
permanente et continue premier
anniversaire du gouvernement de la
gauche et avec lui le passage à la
deuxième phase de son action défini par
françois mitterrand lors de sa deuxième
conférence de presse le 9 juin ce sera
la rigueur après une deuxième
dévaluation du franc pierre mauroy
annonce le blocage des prix et des
revenus pour quatre mois afin de limiter
l'inflation
la décision la plus douloureuse à
prendre dira-t-il plus tard ce virage
nous a touchés dans nos certitudes un
virage où l'on voit aussi le style
évolue et le tribun parfois lyrique la
s'efface devant le gestionnaire prudent
mais décider
j'accepte d'être un paratonnerre de
conduire la politique du pays avec des
serments tout ce qui est en harmonie
tous deux au contraire peut faire
problème
au fil des jours sachant bien que nous
avons des objectifs et que nous y
reviendrons déjà le pc rue dans les
brancards et tandis que les
sidérurgistes de donna crient à la
trahison pierre mauroy rappelle la
nécessité de l'union début 83 on entre
dans la campagne des municipales à
laquelle le premier ministre participe
activement
jusque là le pari du chômage maintenue
sur la crête des deux
et gagner mais l'inflation dérape et le
commerce extérieur plombe les
municipales sont un avertissement pour
la gauche
et si pierre mauroy est acclamé en
vainqueur à lille on commence à
s'interroger dans l'opinion comme à
l'élysée sur l'opportunité de son
maintien à matignon lui même ne souhaite
pas devenir le premier ministre d'une
troisième d'évaluation elle interviendra
pourtant quelques jours plus tard après
une longue hésitation de françois
mitterrand pierre mauroy forme son
troisième gouvernement
le deuxième plan de rigueur économies
budgétaires emprunt obligatoire et
prélèvement de 1 % pour la sécurité
sociale est adopté dans la foulée
pendant plusieurs mois pierre mauroy
sera quasiment absent de la scène
publique c'est le président de la
république qui montent au créneau pour
justifier et expliquer la nouvelle
rigueur une politique tiendra en octobre
le soutien résolu du congrès socialiste
de bourg en bresse
si la balance du commerce extérieur
s'améliore l'inflation fin 83 atteint 9
et demi pour cent au lieu des 8 prévus
et le chômage dépasse les 2 millions
les sondages se suivent inexorablement
et pour pierre mauroy il est temps de se
préoccuper de l'opinion à l'état de
grâce a succédé la politique de rigueur
cela ne va pas sans poser quelques
problèmes sans quelques difficultés
c'est pourquoi nous devons nous
appliquer à les lever sa reconquête de
l'eau vive l'année 84 sera celle de la
restructuration industrielle et de la
contestation pour pierre mauroy greffe
chez talbot le gouvernement ordonne
l'évacuation de lusine mécontentement
des routiers fronde des agriculteurs
manifestations monstres pour l'école l'a
privé comme la laïque marche sur paris
des sidérurgistes de lorraine qui refuse
le plan à si la présence de georges
marchais à leurs côtés concrétise la
fissure dans l'union de la gauche dont
pierre mauroy est considéré comme le
garant la mise au net
annoncée par françois mitterrand la
clarification voulue par le premier
ministre se fera sous forme d'un vote de
confiance il
d'où les lèvres par le pc qui reprend
aussitôt après ses critiques de la
politique du gouvernement jusqu'au bout
en dépit d'une incrédulité grandissante
de l'opinion
pierre mauroy aura essayé de faire
passer la conviction et la détermination
qui l'animé
celui que vous avez devant vous un
portrait qui a été fait il ya quelques
semaines mais nous essayons de réagir le
plus vite possible à chaud à cette
information donc la démission du
gouvernement de pierre mauroy et le
choix de son successeur qui sera donc
laurent fabius
je propose de retrouver tout de suite
jean-michel mercurol qui est l elysée et
qui en main la lettre de démission de
monsieur mauroy et la réponse du
président de la république oui je
voudrais vous lire très rapidement
quelques passages de la lettre du
premier ministre salam de démission
comme nous avons constaté la nécessité
lors des différentes conversations que
nous avons eues ces dernières semaines
quant à l'avenir du gouvernement une
phase nouvelle s'engage écrit monsieur
mauroy la décision que vous avez annoncé
le 12 juillet de consulter le peuple
français s'inscrit dans cette
perspective
j'estime comme vous que le moment est
venu de changer de gouvernement
un passage maintenant de la lettre la
réponse du président de la république
comme nous en sommes convenus au cours
de nos récents entretiens l'évolution de
la situation politique appelle
maintenant la formation d'un nouveau
gouvernement
j'accède en conséquence la demande que
vous avez présenté pour mettre fin à vos
fonctions
plus que tout autre j'ai été en mesure
depuis trois ans d'apprécier le courage
la détermination et la loyauté avec
lesquels vous avez rempli votre charge
la marque de votre action restera dans
l'histoire de notre temps voilà bernard
a voilà donc un changement de
gouvernement un changement d'homme et le
suppose aussi un changement de style car
laurent fabius ce n'est pas pierre
mauroy
oui changement de style à travers les
hommes avant éventuellement d'être un
changement de style à travers la
politique changement de style à travers
les hommes alors là il est flagrant
quand on voit les deux hommes côte à
côte
pierre mauroy est le produit type de du
socialisme français traditionnel la
venue du nord d'un milieu d'enseignants
c'est le son père était enseignant lui
aussi venu du nord est avec cette espèce
de solidité
un peu
un peu paysanne un peu ouvrière aussi
syndicalistes que l'on trouve souvent
chez les vieux militants socialistes et
pierre mauroy avait participé en 1971 à
la rénovation du parti socialiste avec
françois mitterrand à l'occasion du
congrès d'epinay
c'était un ancien de ce qu'on appelait
alors les ses filles oh mais il a été la
pièce maîtresse du nouveau parti
socialiste lancée par françois
mitterrand et ensuite quand un vétéran
est arrivé à la présidence de la
république il a été son premier ministre
au cours donc de quasiment trois ans son
premier ministre très loyal puisqu'il y
avait une très vieille tradition de
collaboration entre les deux hommes
depuis 1971 au début très populaire
parce qu'on oublie un peu souvent au
moment de son arrivée à matignon
pierre mauroy a bénéficié d'une
popularité de ce monstre ordinaire dans
tous les électorats car il apparaissait
comme un socialiste très modérée très
ouvert et il rassuré un peu ce qui
inquiétait la présence des communistes
au gouvernement l'impopularité est venue
après payer la vigueur par la suite avec
la rigueur économique exactement et
ensuite davantage encore avec la rigueur
renforcée à partir de 1983 différence
d'hommes manifeste laurent fabius grand
bourgeois 38 ans il va voir 39 ans chose
comme ça un grand bourgeois
ils listent un énarque donc je disais
tout à l'heure et c'est aussi un
collaborateur de longue date et proche
du pré dans la république puisqu'il a
commencé à travailler quand ça
mitterrand à partir de 1977 alors
politiquement les deux remarques ce
qu'on peut faire ce soir donc l'une je
la faisais tout à l'heure le président
de république a visiblement décidé de
changer tout à la fois puisque avec
l'annoncé du référendum c'était un
changement de style dans sa façon de
gouverner la semaine dernière jeudi
dernier avec le changement de
gouvernement maintenant c'est
probablement la gestion de la france qui
va être envisagée d'une autre façon
n'est pas sûr que cette gestion sur le
fond change
quant à l'essentiel enfin deuxième chose
il ya une volonté de renouveler non
seulement l'image mais aussi
probablement les lits les relations avec
l'opposition ou avec les différents
partis de la majorité
laurent fabius va entamer ce qui
apparaît déjà comme
troisième phase du septennat de françois
mitterrand un changement de premier
ministre un changement de gouvernement
profondeur à votre avis en profondeur
c'est à dire un changement de politique
la rigueur ne changera certainement pas
et laurent fabius on a incarné une
partie puisque comme ministre de
l'industrie il était chargé depuis
quelques mois de mener les
restructurations industrielles qui sont
la clé de la rigueur économique donc
pour l'essentiel qui est la politique
économique
la désignation de laurent fabius et une
confirmation de la rigueur bien je
propose de découvrir de suite le
portrait de laurent fabius que nous
essayons de mettre à l'antenne le plus
rapidement possible je pense notre
réalisateur peut l'envoyer dès
maintenant donc le portrait du nouveau
premier ministre monsieur leur encontre
à 37 ans c'est le benjamin du
gouvernement au sein du conseil on
l'appelle parfois le surdoué de l'équipe
aujourd'hui superministre les obstacles
qui se dressent devant laurent fabius
sont autrement plus difficile que ce
qu'il a eu à franchir jusqu'ici dans sa
vie est en train de la police n'a ici
pour saluer la victoire au cinquième
semaine de laurent fabius que je me
permets de serrer la main au nom de tous
les téléspectateurs
descendez à côté de nous laurent
descendez à côté de nous et bien tous
nos compliments
monsieur le président vous félicite tous
nous inviter les spectateurs sont là qui
piaffent d'impatience je vous applaudir
on peut l'applaudir encore vous savez il
le mérite
bravo laurent fabius quel est votre âge
s'il vous plaît
normalien agrégé énarque là encore un
parcours unique pour laurent fabius
surtout qu'au bout de ce parcours il y
as politiquement la gauche
à l'époque ce type d'enseignement et des
origines bourgeoises conduisait plus
commodément a penché à droite une chance
la rencontre avec françois mitterrand
qui en fait bientôt un conseiller
personnel
laurent fabius aura une ascension rapide
dans le sillage du premier secrétaire
il sera son chef de cabinet son
porte-parole fera partie de l'état major
pour la campagne présidentielle
entre temps il deviendra député de
seine-maritime et maire-adjoint de grand
quevilly
chacun des pas de cette carrière sera
guidée par françois mitterrand
nul ne s'étonne donc en mai 81
de trouver laurent fabius parmi les
ministres de pierre mauroy et sont des
gens comme tout le monde c'est parce
qu'il faut avoir la grosse tête change
rien ce qui compte c'est pas le décorum
ce qui compte ce fonds d'appeler téké
choisi est celui là il a changé et il va
changer depuis chaque fois que l'on
parle d'un remplacement éventuel de
pierre mauroy à matignon
le nom de laurent fabius figure en bonne
place dans la presse parmi les favoris
voilà laurent fabius qui est donc le
nouveau premier ministre je vous
rappelle donc l'information essentielle
de ce soir pierre mauroy a présenté tout
à l'heure au président de la république
la démission de son gouvernement le chef
de l'état a donc choisi monsieur laurent
fabius comme nouveau premier ministre
qui va donc maintenant former le
gouvernement
voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire ce soir sur
cette information que nous avons essayé
de traiter le plus rapidement possible
en votre compagnie à chaud la météo
maintenant avec brigitte simonetta oui
définir la situation météorologique de
demain est assez simple un seul mot
suffit
idan ni meilleure ni pire qu'aujourd'hui
regardez la photo sa télé l'anticyclone
n'a pas bougé il est toujours à la même
place et nous pousse
nous sommes toujours pris dans ce flux
de nord dans cette terre instable et
froid
résultat sur la carte de demain donc de
la manche orientale au bassin parisien
ou lyonnais aux alpes du nord à temps
nuageux avec des éclaircies l'après-midi
petite éclaircie sur le bord sud de
cette zone partout ailleurs de très
belles éclaircies et toujours du vrai
bouton sur la méditerranée l'accord
cette fois son mistral le bleu terme
mais reste stable sur la moitié nord de
18 à 23 degrés mais est en hausse sur la
moitié sud de 23 à 30 degrés maximum sur
la corse
demain mercredi 18 juillet le soleil se
lèvera 6 heures 6 couchera 21h40
fêteront les frédéric laisser roger
zabel qui vous présentera les dernières
informations aux environs de 22 h 55
demain 12h40 cinquantaine de 12h et 18h
30 c'est la vie je vous retrouverai à
20h bonsoir